très vive tension proche orient au
lendemain de l'attentat-suicide riffa
qui a fait 19 morts
une action unanimement condamné par la
communauté internationale qui a
également vivement réagi après le raid
israélien mené ce matin contre la syrie
une attaque en guise de représailles et
d'avertissements samah soula
la riposte a eu lieu là où on ne
l'attendait pas en syrie
l'aviation israélienne a bombardé une
cible proche de damas
il s'agirait d'un camp d'entraînement du
djihad islamique
l'organisation qui a revendiqué
l'attentât d'hier haïfa un objectif dans
stratégie que politique
israël lance un avertissement à tous les
pays qu'ils soutiendraient d'une manière
ou d'une autre les actions terroristes
menées contre israël nous avons mis en
garde à plusieurs reprises tous les pays
concernés spécialement la syrie où les
sièges du jihad islamique
la syrie accuse l'aviation israélienne
d'avoir visé un site civil mais elle a
choisi de répliquer par la voie
diplomatique
damas par le de grave escalade et
demandent la révocation d'urgence du
conseil de sécurité de l'onu depuis son
quartier-général de beyrouth
le jihad islamique a pour sa part
affirmé n'avoir aucun combattant en
syrie le raid israélien
le premier depuis 30 ans contre la syrie
a été conjointement condamnés par le
président égyptien et le chancelier
allemand qui a estimé que l'on ne
pouvait pas accepter ce qui s'est passé
en syrie en cette veille de kippour la
fête la plus sacré du judaïsme
israël enterrait ses morts ici la
victime et chrétienne elle se trouvait
hier dans ce restaurant d'haifa
lorsqu'une bombe humaine a fait
irruption
c'est elle un hadith al sirr jara date
que l'on voit this immortaliser son voeu
d'être martyrs son acte a tué 19
personnes et blessé 50 autres elle avait
29 ans elle était avocate son frère et
son cousin membres du jihad islamique
ont été tués il ya trois mois par
l'armée israélienne
ce matin à jénine la maison de sa
famille a été dynamitée quelques heures
après deux raids sur gaza qui n'ont pas
fait de victime pour l'heure israël
semble avoir exclu de s'en prendre
directement à yasser arafat
mais le chef de l'autorité palestinienne
se sait en sursis attentats répression
rien ne semble pouvoir aujourd'hui
mettre fin à cette logique meurtrière
c'est donc là promis